I'm uh Manuel and I'm going to be
talking about MCP is boring or why we
losing the sparkle of
LLMs. So just a little bit about me. I'm
Manuel. I'm program with AI on Twitter.
My GitHub's uh Vasin and I've been a
software engineer for 25 years. Probably
veteran coder at this point I guess. And
I've been writing a lot of common list
and I'm bringing that up because it's
going to be relevant for for this talk.
But I've been an embedded engineer. I
love search engine. I love databases. I
love backend coding. I've um all the all
the coding basically that's like
boilerplate and backend and those kinds
of things. I've been coding with LM
since 2022 since the alpha of copilot I
think. Uh and then when chat GPT came
out and decided to do all my coding with
LM and I've been pretty much obsessed
with it since then. does my program with
AI Twitter account which uh where I
share all my tips and all the things
I've
discovered and we've been using tool
calling and LLMs for I I guess it came
out like two years ago we've been using
it increasingly they're great right
because uh LLMs are language producers
so what that means we've written a lot
about tools so per se LLMs know a lot
about calling tools and I I mean we've
written a lot about tool using in our
literature uh in our code and they've
been reinforced. So we have a much much
content to talk about tool calling and
what that means is that LLMs can produce
language that uh calls tools in
structured format is what we usually do
and then uh we map the structured format
that comes out to just basically call a
function, call an API, call an MCP
server and it's magical the text come
back. We don't really need a schema. the
LLM can continue working on it, can
answer questions about it. And what that
means is that now we can instead of
writing code, having to parse schemas,
having to validate them, having to be
really careful, we can just talk to the
machine, say like please, you know,
please call the API and then give me
that information and we're done. Pretty
amazing, right? I think uh everybody
here uses agents and knows pretty much
what I what I mean. Uh what does that
look like in practice? I think uh this
is something that is uh fairly
straightforward. It's the standard
example of what's the weather like in
San Francisco. The assistant can do some
chain of thought for example and uh
checks what tools it has available which
are provided as a schema in the context
that's being sent to the LLM. It
basically says in a special token format
these are your tools this is how you
call them. this is what it means to call
them. And the LLM then decides that, you
know, getting the current weather might
be a pretty good tool to use uh to get
the the weather from in San Francisco,
right? And the tool then, which is a
deterministic piece of code, is going to
call whatever weather API you have,
fetch your current conditions, return
that as JSON maybe, and the MLM rece
receiving this JSON does a new inference
and outputs an answer to the user's
request. No magic there. Um, well,
there's no magic in how it works, but as
soon as you've uh wired up a few tools,
especially your own tools, you realize
how magical that is.
Um, but great, we have MCP now, which
allows any kind of LLM app to interact
with tools that other people have built.
So, you can download an MCP to interact
with GitHub. You can download one to
interact with Blender. You can download
one to interact with your own files. You
can download one to interact with the
temperature in your room if you have if
you have built such an MCP. It's uh
absolutely mind-boggling possibilities.
The problem is when you give an MCP too
many tools, right? Um, so I'm I'm just
going through like we it's absolutely
magic. It's amazing. Um, but if you give
an element too many tools, if you give
it like a 100 tools, it's going to be
well, should I call get weather or
should I call like search internet for
weather in San Francisco, it's kind of
hard to decide and and the LLM like ends
up calling the wrong tool or uh use the
wrong schema or like doesn't really
understand what parameters to give to a
certain
tool. So, it's not great. And the other
the other problem is that when you call
a tool that means the arguments that the
LLM is going to give that tool and then
per induction those that we are going to
provide to that tool have to be
inferenced by the LLM. So if we if we
want to call the tool and say like you
know we have this like fragment of
document please search for something
similar somewhere else you have to emit
this part of document which probably is
already in the context higher above
anyway.
and repeat that to give it to the tool.
Uh, which is pretty expensive. It's
pretty slow. Uh, I think you all know
that where it's going to be like spinny
spinny spinny spinny and actually is
just copy pasting something that's
literally just above. If you if you go
back to the San Francisco example, it's
like a a
lower less impressive
um example of that, but it repeats the
San Francisco, right?
So the problem is that all the tokens
that come back from that tool also have
to be put in the LLM. So if you do
something like
um getting the weather and you only want
the wind speed, you'll still have the
whole JSON that gives you the date and
gives you all kinds of information about
the sun and the moon and but you
actually only care about like a single
number that's like a single token. So
you've wasted 2,000 tokens on something
that could have been answered much more
quickly.
Um, what does that look like is, uh,
imagine if you have a CRM and you ask
for the contact information of OpenAI.
U, what it's going to do is going to
call its tool that's called get CRM
companies. That's that's like the tool
that exists. And this is a massive
response because there's 36 companies in
your database. So, you end up having
this like insane list of companies. And
um then at the end you basically just
look at the email of OpenAI and you
could say, "Oh, bad tool, right? Like
get a tool that's called get CRM
company." But then if you misspell
OpenAI, maybe that won't work, right?
Like you have all these like little you
starting starting to optimize for
certain case where you like only want
one company, then maybe you only want
the contact information for the company.
So you add a flag like contact is equal
to true and you end up with like
something crazy like GraphQL at the end
of the day. if you want to cover all
your bases and then the model's going to
create wrong GraphQL and it's going to
go downhill.
So tools have limitations, right? It's
great to have all the information of the
companies because suddenly I can ask
questions like who's in San Francisco
and it's going to be able to answer
these like fuzzy queries that I maybe
never asked for. Um the problem is you
end up having 20,000 tokens. It cost you
like 50 cents. you're waiting for 5
minutes before you get the answer to
your query
and that's
not it's not great. So we can engineer
around it but really what we're doing is
uh why are MCPs basically so restricted
and I think it's because they're boring
like we are not leveraging all the
things we could actually do with LLM
with code generated by LM with the
coding the tool calling around it for
example why don't we pass the chat
history along with LLM calls the LM call
can decide to the tool can just decide
to to discard it right but we already
have all this information in the context
of an application why not also pass it
to the tool call so that we can say you
know we've called this thing like 15
times just reuse the arguments from
before for example or use this as you
know a search query um so that would be
one example it's pretty pretty simple
it's like you know please just give me
the the chat history that is present as
metadata to your tool call you could
also give me your memories. If you have
an LM application that has memories and
you have persistent knowledge like why
not give that to my tool to say like
well you've already called me 15 times
like maybe my location is San Francisco
then I can just call get weather and get
weather will look at my memories and say
like oh there's a location memory here
you go um pretty easy extension that
allows you to do so so so much more at a
very very low cost and another thing is
like if you can attach files in your LLM
application like why not pass these
files along or at least a path or like
at least their
metadata dangerous right like the
security implications and the problem is
also there's many many many different
NLM apps that all have different
modalities so suddenly you have to
design a protocol that covers all these
different cases maybe I have an
application where people can like draw
little images so suddenly how do I pass
that as as an attached file like maybe I
have a graph rag how do I pass my graph
structure
Lots of questions, lot of boring
engineering. We've done that in the 90s
and the 2000s with ontologies and
semantic web and graphs and triplets and
XML
schemas could go back to that.
Um but one very easy thing we could also
do um is you know before you call the
tool why not give the the user a little
UI on what they want to attach and how
they want to attach and maybe edit the
arguments because why not very very easy
to at least you know if if I have the
LLM write a whole tool call and I it
opens up and it says like well I'm
searching for the company
like open AI and it's misspelled then
the user can go in and say like um this
is open AI it's different or maybe like
suddenly it's searching for Oracle for
some reason you can say like no no no
this is not the tool call that I want
currently the only interaction we have
is like allow which is boring is square
it's like why not think wild there the
next thing we can do is like well let
the user edit the tool result before we
paste all of this stuff back right like
if I get 30 pages of results as a user
it's actually faster for me to just edit
down these results and maybe the UI is
even nice to do
instead of waiting 10 minutes and
spending 50 cents to have the LLM do it.
Um so to show you an example of what
that can look like is um you
can say I want to find all the customers
with overdue invoices, right? We get a
tool call. Imagine we have a SQLite or
like a SQL tool. So it's able to write
SQL queries and it's going to have this
query CRM thing with a with a filter.
And before we before it gets cool called
we have this little approve reject which
we know and a little edit dialogue which
in here is a very raw way of editing it
but it allows you to to edit the
arguments before they go before they go
further.
Um so suddenly when the call comes back
you can actually edit the results as
well
and tune your tune your your query or
like realize oh it's a wrong call like
let me go back to the edit step let me
do the call again you I don't need the
LLM to do that kind of stuff right it's
uh and that to me especially when I'm
doing
uh a lot of you know database queries
those kinds of things if I do the on
query and I have the only the option
allow and I get back 10,000 things I'm
like damn I'm like messed up and if it's
an agent thing I have to rewind the
whole agent run instead of being able to
edit this one tool. I've got a whole set
of thoughts around context editing but
uh this goes beyond the the the scope of
this talk and you're welcome to come
talk to me to to get more info.
Um,
so LLMs are so much more, right? They're
language producers. They can create
every word under the sun. They've been
trained under every word under the sun.
And you can do the weirdest crap with
them. You can do poems about Oracle. You
can do right like those are even boring
things you can do. If you look at
everything like AI red teams are doing
and if you go into starting to talk to
it like a terminal, it's a terminal.
like basically everything you tell the
LLM is going to be what the LLM's going
to pretend to be. So this gives us like
a lot of leverage because they've been
trained so hard and really reinforced to
learn about code, right? They're great
at coding these days. You can like
oneshot entire applications. You can
call like 15,000 APIs that have been
like recently built. Like Sonnet 4 is
amazing at knowing stuff that was just
like built two two months ago. It
oneshotss things that I never thought
would be possible before, but why are we
stuck with like tools that only that
don't even work that well, right? Like I
know a tool call is a function call. Why
are there so bad at function calling
when at the same time they can generate
code that is so much better?
Um,
so code is a tool, right? There's many
things that are called like even if I
have just a SQL tool, I'm basically
giving it code because a SQL query is
code. If I have an edit file tool, I can
give it code and you can write code that
calls tools that calls code that runs an
agent. You can do all this like infinite
recursion stuff at the inference time.
And um
basically you can tell an
LLM please create the tool that I want.
Right? If I if I give it a database
schema, I can say like, well, please
create the tool get company contact. No
problem. Every LLM by now can do that. I
can probably do it with like a three
billion model, three billion parameter
model locally. Um, and so there are
these kind of like magical genies that
can just like create whatever you want
at the moment you need it in the way you
want it and modify it, right? So why
don't we leverage that instead of being
stuck with this like you can only call
functions, you can only call functions
with this schema that we've given you
and it's like static and you can't even
modify it. So the only prompt
engineering you actually kind of need to
do agents is like write the code to do
X, right? And there there's a couple of
papers around it. Um I haven't linked
them but there's the Voyager paper uh
from two years ago already and there's
the I think code elicits better tool
actions something like that which is a
very short paper that basically says
like you know just like write code to do
tools um and I've been on the LLM stuff
pretty early to do code like once the
instruct versions came out and and
writing my little tools was the first
thing I did. I was like, I want to write
the shell script to do this XYZ and I
want to do the shell script to do XYZ. I
would run it. I would paste the result
back into chat GPT which is basically
like a like um I'm the tool caller at
that point and that was really really
useful. So the whole time before I read
these papers, before MCP came out,
before tool calling came out, I was like
generating these shell scripts or
generating little applications to do
these kinds of queries or generating SQL
queries that would push back. And so it
was already crappy back then, but it
hasn't really gotten significantly
better, right? Like it feels that tool
calling is still stuck at this like
GPT35 kind of intelligence. I I don't
know why, but they're not that great.
However, they they're so good at writing
code that the only MCP I think I need is
like eval right instead of copy pasting
things putting it in the shell copy
pasting it back all I need is like eval
around it and it can be bash and you can
look at it every coding agent does most
of its work with actually bash calls
they call gp they call find they call ls
they call said when they're like
struggling with their edit file tool
right it's like just editing a file they
actually don't know how to do it and
when they really fail at calling their
tool they're just like, "Ah, [__] it.
I'm going to write set code," which is
an insane tool anyway as well.
Um, so you can realize like, why do we
even need MCPS when uh we just have
eval? And so here's an example where
eval is actually SQL, right? And I just
ask it like how many orders did customer
John Smith placed the last month? And I
don't even tell it what the database is.
I just say like you have a SQL
evaluation tool. So the first thing it's
going to do is going to be like well
what tables do I have right and it says
like oh well I found customers and
orders so you know let me look at their
schema and it says like oh well
customers you know they have like a
field called name and then there's like
a field customer ID in the table orders
with a date like yeah I know how to do a
SQL query to do that right and so it's
it's doing the structure loading it
looks like the schema of customers and
orders and says like oh there look
there's customer ID And now it can just
write a SQL query that does the result
of the orders, the join that it needs
with the aggregation that it needs and
just returns the result. And the crazy
thing here is like if you had a thing
that's called like orders or customer
place last month, maybe the LLM won't
realize that actually has to pass, you
know, uh first name, last name, for
example. So the first tool call fails
and then it like repeats its tool call
and says like well oh the date format is
wrong. you have to do like minus 30
days. So it tries with minus 30 days and
then suddenly gets like a huge table
with all the invoice items. It's like
okay cool now I have the information I'm
going to aggregate as an LLM get the
wrong number because they can't do
addition and you wasted 5,000 tokens and
you get like a wrong response while this
actually probably takes like you know
500 tokens and you get a
deterministic repeatable kind of query
that can reuse.
So this is why eval is such a such a
nice tool is that oops why did this go
so fast but if we take it to the next
step is like once it works you know why
not store this query uh why not say like
oh now we have like a get customer order
amount query um and so the way you can
do that for example with SQL is that you
can just create a view to do it and then
suddenly you don't even need to look at
the tables you don't need to do
complicated SQL you just do like oh
select amount from view And so this is
what it looks like is um this thing is
going to run it's like couple of queries
like maybe it even needs to do things in
sequence where it's like going to be
like oh I'm going to select the orders
and I see like oh okay I have to join
this table okay let's let me do it again
and then I have to do this has this
complicated code but them being good
coders it knows how to turn like 15
queries into a single view and um at
that point and this looks like not the
example of the view that I was trying to
And so, um, I I can show you that live.
I I used the wrong uh the wrong
screenshots.
Um,
but that shows you that you can easily
create tools and functions and views and
whatever. And so when you create a lot
of functions and views and make them
nice to reuse, that's called a library,
right? So instead of like exposing a
GitHub tool, you just say like, well,
your eval now has access to the GitHub
library and it's preconfigured. you
don't need to deal with like OS tokens
and whatever. You just have like this
whole API to do interactions with
GitHub. And funnally is like if you put
10,000 functions into an API, the LLM
actually knows how to use them. If you
put them as tool calls, it doesn't,
which I don't know why they get so bad
once you add tool calls. Um, I mean,
they've gotten better, right? like
Sonnet 4, uh, GPT41, like all these
newer models have been trained to be a
little bit better at tool calling, but
you still like very very quickly run
into like weird things where doesn't
understand the parameters. And
however, they're so good at writing code
these days that I rarely have to fix
anything in code, even for my own
libraries, right? Like I just point them
at my set of functions in a header file
and then it works. So why instead of
doing the CRM MCP, you know, just do
like import star from CRM and then
you're done. You can not only do you
have all the tools that you used to have
as a as an MCP, but now you can create
your own tools that are really rich. So
you
know, just build the get company info
tool.
um um because you you what you don't
need to build an MCP get company info
tool because you can actually just
generate the code to call CRM list info
and then you have like uh you know it's
able to put a for loop around it. able
to put any kind of code around it. And
so if you think a step further is that
these tools and the code that's
generated is like not just for the LLM,
but like a lot of it is for us as well.
So why don't we use the fact that we can
use code now to build tools that are
much richer than just a function call
with like a little JSON window that you
have to click in to edit it. um if you
can even edit it, but instead have tools
that build UIs for us, right? So instead
of just incorporating a JavaScript
interpreter that has like under the hood
access to libraries, but then still on
the surface just calls like functions,
um why not have something in the LLM
host application that allows us to do
UIs very easily? And so I've I've built
a couple of prototypes around it, but
just to show you what this would look
like. If we go back to editing, you
know, the tool input and the tool
output, if you give the LLM the
opportunity to say like, well, if the
user wants to edit my input, you know,
give it like a good UI instead of a
little text window where you can edit
JSON. And so this could, if we go back
to the previous example, it could like
output some kind of UI DSL that's
rendered by the LLM host. And suddenly
instead of having to edit like JSON
fields, you get a slider, you get like
drop downs, you get all kinds of things
which the user can validate or tweak or
you know attach a file say like no I
don't want it to know about my memories
and then call the tool. Um, and maybe
there's like preferences you can save.
Like there's all kinds of things you can
do around it, right? And then similarly,
you can have a UI that allows you to
edit the output um, with like maybe a
scroll view and a filter. You can say
like, well, remove this, add this, the
LLM shouldn't know about this, recall
the tool by modifying my previous
inputs. And you get this like rich UI to
do your work.
Um, and so what I built and I I can show
you that live is like a very simple MCP
which has a sandbox.js. It's written in
go and it has two libraries. It has
SQLite library which is loaded and it
has a web server that basically has a
single function that's called register
handler and then you just write
JavaScript for the handler right. Um so
there's a a single call is called eval
and then the LLM when it calls it can
also register rest handlers. So what
this looks like right like there's
execute.js and if you want to load a
file that you've already written if
you're like saying cursor you can use
execute.js JS file. Um, what this means
if I use the same query and raise it's a
prototype. So, I'm a little bit
aggressive on the prompting. It will
suddenly write JavaScript where it's
going to be like, you know, let me look
at the table. So, exactly the stuff from
before, but it's already clever because
it's because it's onet. So, it will
actually look for the company table in
code already. It won't even wait for the
result, right? Like it won't stream back
all the tables in my database. It will
actually already filter them. uh so it
saves on tokens and whatever once they
return these tables in their schema so
you save two tool calls right and you
save a lot of tokens just by the virtue
of having
eval just by the virtue of having it
it's the same tool it has like dbsqlite
query but suddenly we're already like
saving money
um and then in the same call actually I
forgot about it in the same call it
actually already does the querying of it
And it's well possible that you know you
already get like some some stuff at the
beginning. Suddenly you get like the
first 10 companies and then it calls it
again with all the companies and then
the LLM is able to to show the result,
right? And you can see the schema is
super ugly. It like actually doesn't
even take care of printing it as JSON
apparently. just like literally logs it
out with the standard like go syntax and
then you get the query response and this
took two seconds, right? Or like 3
seconds, not 15 tool calls, it took one
tool call.
Um, and so what I can do now is like
just save it as a global function. It
being sonnet and being kind of on crack
cocaine and just like deciding to do 15
things, it like generated 15 functions.
Sure. So now I have all my tools, right?
I've get company's info. I can get a
company by its ID. I can search
companies. I can do all kinds of things
by the virtue of just like two tool
calls. Uh and one of them was just
because of a syntax error because my
prompting is bad because it's a
prototype. So why not create a REST API
endpoint, right? Because it has register
handler. So why not hook up all of these
tools to all of these functions to a
REST API which like all right here you
go, right? like just like not really
hard. It just like calls the thing. Um
because it's on it again, it like
generate like even
more. So, and then I asked it to
generate like a website, right? So, it's
registering a handler for the
JavaScript, it's registering a handler
for the CSS, and it's registering a
handler for the HTML. It already has the
REST endpoints. And boom, now I have a
whole CRM. I don't even need the LLM
anymore. I can just start working with
it. And that was a single tool eval
right so I think we're leaving so much
on the table by focusing on tool calling
and saying like oh there's like agents
there are these little widgets with
these little creatures with tools and
that's our mental model instead of being
like no this is like a magical genie
that can create anything I want when I
want it without even needing any big
information because it's all in training
corpus. You can edit the companies, you
can add new ones which will be stored in
the database. Like this is a real real
CRM. This this this is just I don't even
but I don't need cursor. I don't need
anything. I can just say
like do
it. So to close this off, LMS are
absolute magic and I think you should
think get used to thinking recursively,
right? It's like if you ask the LM to do
something, ask it to do the code to do
something. And then once you have
something that writes the code to do a
certain task, ask it to write the code
to write the code, right? Which is kind
of what I did with the JS sandbox. I
didn't it just give it like JavaScript
with loaded libraries is that suddenly I
have a JavaScript sandbox that you can
use to create libraries that can then be
loaded later on. And those are APIs that
I can then reuse in like different
systems. And it's like all very
circular. I can create everything I want
all the
time and right they create words and
those words create more words and then I
can create words that create an LLM that
create words that create words is it's
it's infinite
um and all of these word ultimately are
going to make things happen in the real
world but if you focus on just the thing
that you need to make happen in the real
world you tend to forget that it's not
just tool calling it's actually we are
engineers the LLMs are engineers
everything is engineering in this case
so just write the code to solve the
problem as we have been used to instead
of saying like we have an agent and
suddenly it does everything that's not
true the LLM writes code that does
everything
um so yeah uh infinite loops of creation
I hope uh you enjoyed this talk and I
hope that you are able to bring back the
magic into LLMs right like the sparkle
sparkle sparkle because um they're so
much more than what we're trying that
what we're thinking of them these days.